One of the things you learned as a
clinical psychologist contra the anti
psychiatrists let's say is that
diagnosis is often a relief to people.
You know there's a problem with being
diagnosed because then you might be
labeled and then the label can follow
you for the rest of your life and once
you're labeled as something,
then strange things happen around you
that is often reinforced that label.
Maybe you start acting it out more
or you adopt it as an identity,
but there's a flip side of that which is
that the last thing that you ever want
to hear when you go see a
physician or psychologist is,
you know,
I've never seen a case like yours before.
Right?
That is not a relief man
because if the messages,
I've never heard anything
like what you're telling me,
the outcome is either going to be not so
good for you or you're not going to get
listened to it all.
Right.
Because you're such an
anomaly that you're,
you're actually in your existence is
annoying to the integrated knowledge
structure of the medical professional
that you are attempting to receive advice
from.
Well,
it's definitely the case
because they didn't,
you know,
if you can be put in a box,
then the box tells the
doctor what to do with you.
And that's actually a
relief to the doctor,
but also a relief to you.
Right?
Because you want to know,
so you come in,
you say,
look,
I can't go out of my house much anymore.
I'm afraid on elevators.
I have heart palpitations and I sometimes
they end up in the emergency room.
Increasingly my,
uh,
interactions in the world are restricted.
I find myself staying at home,
I'm afraid I'm going to
die of a heart attack.
And the psychologist says,
well,
you have egg or a phobia.
It's like lots of people have that.
And here's usually how it develops and
here's the treatment course and you know,
we can probably do something about that.
And it's like,
well,
you're not going to die of
a heart attack now probably.
That's a real relief.
You're not crazy in a completely unique
way and you're crazy in a way that might
be treatable,
you know?
And it's so,
it's such a relief because people
come in there with a pile of snakes of
indeterminate magnitude,
and they walk out with
one manageable snake,
and it's still a snake,
but you know,
one manageable snake beats a hydra right.